Sonia what are the parties there
intending to achieve in this meeting
well essentially it is to try and find
some kind of solution that they can all
agree on in terms of what they can do in
terms of relocating refugees and
migrants asylum seekers that come to
Europe wind up on European Shores from
the North African coast in particular
from Libya as well there have been
divergent opinions on this already
Moltar in Italy started discussing this
back in July when they wanted to see a
more focused approach as they're taking
in the burden of most of those boat
landings from Libya so what they would
like to see are other EU member states
to relocate those who come onto their
shores as quickly as possible to try and
avoid some of the scenes that we've seen
in recent times of migrants and refugees
being cast out at sea for a long time to
come as well and with the
criminalization of certain NGO vessels
as well that has also added an
additional burden that France and
Germany say that they want would like to
have a slightly more nuanced approach to
this they want to see the migrants and
refugees really getting there being
processed in Malta and Italy they're not
too keen on that Malter in Italy and of
course stuck in the middle of this are
those asylum seekers who have been stuck
out at sea for days and even weeks along
this frame after drifting through the
Mediterranean for days these men women
and children have finally arrived in
Malta they're part of a larger group of
265 people who were rescued from three
separate boats in distress only 36 of
them were allowed to dock on the island
the others still remain at sea on a
rescue vessel waiting for their
precarious journey to come to an end
this is the reality for those who set
off from Libya in the hope of seeking
refuge in Europe a little guarantee that
they will survive the journey let alone
gain asylum there is the issue assertion
rescue vessels where we've seen
increased criminalization
stopping and holding vessels out at
Steve denying access to ports this
obviously has a hugely negative effect
on the asylum seekers that are on the
vessels Malta and Italy are on the front
line of Europe's migration crisis and
they share the same complaint they say
they have not received adequate support
from the European Union to deal with a
number of people who have for years been
arriving on their shores the conditions
that caused them to flee war poverty and
hunger remained largely unaddressed and
there is little sign that conditions
will improve and in a seemingly
never-ending saga of human misery it is
the people smuggling networks that have
profited charging vulnerable people
thousands of dollars for a dangerous
passage to Europe meanwhile European
governments wary of their own
anti-immigration movements are reluctant
to be seen be encouraging asylum seekers
and so the dilemma continues the EU has
given millions of dollars to Libya's
Tripoli based government to intercept
vessels leaving the coast but with
little effect with more than 54,000
people arriving in Europe by boat so far
this year
the Maltese authorities say that there
needs to be a different approach to this
humanitarian emergency
we welcome the authorities shown by some
Member States with regards to the
relocation of asylum seekers but of
course being these dock agreements it
means that we are sort of atamira see of
the will of the Member States the dream
of a better life we almost certainly
encourage many more to make the perilous
journey and unless the people smuggling
networks who prey in them are seriously
tackled they will continue to be left
vulnerable of course the challenge in
this is that whatever their agreements
they come up with they're going to have
to try to convince other EU Member
States to be able to take on the extra
load that has been an incredibly
contentious issue as speck
for member states such as Hungary and
Poland and the anti-migrant rhetoric
that has been flourishing there these
past few years has certainly not helped
with that at all whatever agreement is
produced out of here will then take time
to resolve throughout the whole of the
European Union
Sonia thank you for that Sonia gaya go
live for us in Malta